hey guys and welcome back to steam
Punk's a game sports PC focus show where
we talk about all things PC this week we
are talking about the best old games
that you can get from gog.com which we
reckon still hold up well my first game
is pretty old and is the actually the
first game I have a player really see
and that is quest for glory so on GOG
you can get the quest for glory
collection which is question boy a 1 to
5 the first one was released in 1989 so
this is a adventure game slash RPG
hybrid from ceará you start off as an
unknown hero walking into the town or
Spielberg your adventures will take you
from the first game to a whole new land
in the second game and again in the
third and the fourth and the fifth fifth
one's not so great don't play that one
those settings are just so good because
they are in places that don't get
covered a lot in games so yeah the first
one is in a medieval England style town
so go on is in a retinyl Rabia night
star city number three is set in the
African savanna which is amazing because
you then you have to learn it has a like
camp and [ __ ] and fourth is in like a
medieval Russian vampire town which is
my favorite out of all of them and
you'll like be questing helping people
out in the adventure game fashion but
you'll also have a very very detailed
RPG stat sheet you can be a fighter a
wizard or a thief the points that you
put into these abilities will obviously
inform the skills you have access to how
good you are at interacting with people
and things how good you are in combat
and what skills you can use in combat at
the end of a quest for glory just has so
many memorable characters so many like
mechanics that hold up well and it's a
very replayable series because you can
go through the entire Suz again and
again with different classes different
builds different ways of approaching
situations and problems and I feel like
there's always something new to discover
so my games are a tad more recent being
that I am a little younger than year but
one of the fondest memories I have from
my childhood in a game that I still
engage with today is that intro music
from rollercoaster tycoon
it does really well at a bunch of
different things but you can engage with
it how you want to so if you want to
customize the crap out of everything you
can if you want to be that hardcore
gamer that
is looking to unlock level after level
that just get more and more difficult
with the challenge going up but it also
catered really well to kids who just
wanted to make their dream park with a
dream attractions and stuff the sound
effects are brilliant the music is
brilliant you get thrown into maps that
have different restrictions places that
are like redone like water parks but
they're completely failing and being
able to take a scenario like that and
turn it into a thriving theme park is
like consistently satisfying our in dave
was a really fun part of that game
researching new rides new attractions
and the other part that was really fun
was just waiting to arraign and hiking
up the price of umbrellas I'm old enough
to appreciate theme park but I
appreciate that that roller coaster
tycoon took sim games and moved into the
modern era with a whole bunch of more
advanced customizations and seniya
rollercoaster creation all that kind of
stuff well my second GOG pic is slightly
more recent so that's still older than
yours
which is you know this one is the last
Express it's an adventure game by Jordan
Mechner who was famous for creating
Prince of Persia
and the last Express was kind of his
like I'm gonna throw all my money into
this and you know this is gonna be the
the blockbuster of 1996 yeah it wasn't a
blockbuster it didn't do so well there
is still an amazing game with an
incredible concept
you're an American detective on a train
called the Orient Express obviously that
goes across Europe and it's a venture
game where you discover a murder and you
kind of have to work out who on the
train did it and it's got that murder
only or an express sort of mystery of
like you know everyone everyone's very
intimately connected there's a mechanic
whereby you can rewind time using a
Faberge egg so you can go to different
parts of the Train at different times of
the day or not because time just
continually runs eavesdrop on different
conversations and like discover new
actions it's kind of like peeling back
the layers of an interactive play
something like that if you've played
Tacoma that game kind of takes a lot of
inspiration from games like The Lost
Express it was also notable at the time
for using a very expensive form of
animation called rotoscoping which is
you might have seen in films like a
Scanner Darkly it looks really janky and
shaped by today's standards now at the
time was pretty amazing but even so the
mechanics of the lots expressed and the
venture of it still holds up and it's a
style of adventure game that not a lot
of people do these days so that's why
it's still unique and that's why I kind
of like going back to play it once in a
while I was really stuck between which
of these games to choose I'm a big fan
of Might and Magic 8 Dave the destroyer
but III just couldn't imagine this
episode going up with the best old games
that you can still pick up dog that are
great today without mentioning here is a
Magic three complete edition which you
can pick up on GOG so this game came out
in 1999 and I really honestly feel like
there's not really anything like it it's
such a standout example of a strategy
game that just has so much content
packed in I feel like they don't make
games like this anymore
there's sprawling massive campaigns that
will take you hours and hours dozens of
hours dozens of multiplayer maps which
you can play with a friend or you can
just play against AI me and my brother
would play hot seat swapping back and
forth each turn the game lets you pick
between ton of different factions which
are also fascinatingly distinct they've
all got their own heroes that only occur
within that faction they all have their
own creature types creature buildings
town design music that comes with that
specific faction that you weren't here
if you're playing any other faction and
all feel so vastly different to play
that even if you were taking on the same
map with a different faction it's a
whole new experience the game really
rewards exploration it rewards timing so
you play this game from day to day you
can only move a certain amount for the
day so you need to balance what
resources you need to collect what
combat encounters you can afford to take
on without losing too many troops the
game also rewards careful planning hero
building your heroes have levels and can
be created in a multitude of different
ways
you have your might heroes and your
magic heroes there are tons of spells
that you can either use or not artifacts
to equip them with the same is so good
and it's really interesting because I
don't feel like even the developers
themselves ever made a heroes game that
is as good as here isn't my magic 3 I
just wanted to a quick shout to fallout
on right you can also get on GOG 1997
fallout 1 is still the best Fallout game
and as what 76 comes in and there's a
multiplayer need to remember whatever
research all out and that's a hardcore
computer RPG on an isometric grid that's
with great turn-based combat and the
ability to just talk to everyone and
complete the whole game by without
shooting of cheating employed while
we're having an aside if you've only
heard of Siberia because of the third
game that came out or sacred because of
the I think might have also been the
third game that came out a couple years
ago both of those really bad the early
games the early sacred and Siberia games
also on GOG also really good so after
all that positivity old games let's talk
about how much everybody still hates
loot boxes and microtransactions we just
totally fair and you guys definitely
left your comments to that effect last
week alright so Phillip Tyndall on
YouTube said that my justification for
loot boxes feeling really really good to
open are the exactly the reason why
they're being outlawed they're basically
the video game version of again we
fought machines which I completely agree
with that's completely fine yeah but
obviously you do kind of need to be
aware that yourself yeah I guess I am as
a responsible adult which is exactly I
think why there's been a lot of uproar
about how loot boxes are affecting kids
people like kids like teenagers who may
not like be in a place where they can be
fiscally responsible and make their own
choice what they want to do with their
money being directly marketed to and I
do agree that that's where we run into a
problem on the site user snuggles prime
said I'm fine with loot boxes not case
in free-to-play games a lot of
free-to-play games need to rely on RNG I
feel to maintain profits or else is the
chance they could go pay to win which no
one wants I feel like microtransactions
not loot boxes in paid multiplayer games
are fine as well if they promise to
continue to update the game with the
funds they get from those micro
transactions like Rainbow six siege is a
game that they plan to only support for
a year but people began playing it and
supporting it
I think Rainbow six stages are really
good yeah it's one of the best examples
yeah it's crazy that to think that it
came out like five years ago
and crazy like that and it's still going
the eSports scene is very active and
then you update upcoming thickens boss
and they are
thing and good only we thought you know
who have been kind of like the one of
the main perpetrators of like bad
microtransaction yeah how much like yeah
buying a treasure map to see all the
treasure in Assassin's Creed yeah I
think micro transactions are easier to
digest in loot boxes as well because you
know you want horse armor you're
straight-up saying you're paying five
dollars for some and exactly what that
armor looks like so I feel like that's
also a more honest and digestible way to
get people to keep putting money into
your game than the invisible prize pack
of whatever that is everything we've got
for you guys this week do let us know
where your favorite old games are that
still hold up now and we will see you
again next week
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]